Arby with the stage 32 happy writers are
you you're seeing them pitch right or no
the way it works is we work with over
300 executives in Hollywood
they're all again producers agents
managers directors the development
people making films or people
representing screenwriters they are on
one side of the computer screen and you
are on the other and you could be
anywhere in the world and it's done via
Skype and you have eight minutes okay
and you get two we recommend that for
about four of those minutes you pitch
your script you know that you are
concise and that you get it out in four
minutes
and that leaves you four minutes to
speak with the executive and at that
point is that one or two things happens
okay
well the executive is going to have a
conversation with you why did you decide
to write this why is this story personal
personal to you how long have you been
writing what else have you done act
those kinds of questions at that point
at the end of the eight minutes the
executive he either requests the script
or he'll explain why he doesn't feel
like he wants to read the material okay
and if he does accept the material he
will you know once he's done reading it
give feedback to Joey who runs that
division of stage 32 as to what the next
steps are
or he may contact them writer directly
and say you know I want to read
something else or can we get on the
phone or whatever so it's immediate
access right to that executive and most
of these executives work for you know
bigger management firms bigger
production companies who most have a no
unsolicited material rule so you can't
query him anyway so this breaks down
that barrier what are some of the things
you see no writers do I mean you get to
watch their sky Tommy I said but I've
also been you know I've also been at you
know I've spoken at other pitchfest and
things of that nature so I get to see a
lot of pitching like you also teach some
classes on pitching so yeah
well so we know writers are naturally
more sort of intense and nervous maybe
than than other creatives sure what are
some of the pros and cons you see when
they go up in front of these individuals
or even from their own home skyping well
I think that you know the biggest thing
is they don't know this story you know I
mean that's the biggest problem or they
get
too far into the story sometimes like in
other words you know you're you have
four minutes more or less um you have a
but you know you want to leave time to
have a conversation so they'll get a too
much too far into the secondary
characters so too far into you know
small plot points okay they don't follow
the arc of the main character and what
happens there one of the best pieces of
advice I had when I was pitching was
take me through the middle of the third
act you know give me your main character
and take me to the middle of the third
act I don't want to know the ending and
something that everybody's like this
some people want to know the ending I
don't want to know the ending I want you
to take me to a point where I am so
desperate to know the ending that I have
to read the script okay and you know so
everybody has their own ways of doing
things some people like when you say you
know which draws meets you know
Spaceballs and you know they like that
kind of thing as a slaughter some people
just like you to get right into the
story but the idea is to be concise to
get your mean the mean arc out and to
leave them wanting a little bit more at
the end so no more TMI not too much
information and tease them tease them
enough yeah I mean some people will say
you know I you know will tell me what
happens you know but I but my experience
I've seen it much more that you know we
me with a little something like yeah
like you know I want to read it now like
you know I want to know what the heck
happens you know know your logline know
your main character know your arcs know
your first act break because your first
act break matters because if you're
doing it correctly I know you're
inciting incident of course and what
propels you know your main character off
on its journey what is a journey entail
and ultimately what is the goal believe
them wondering if they get there or
maybe even how they get there at the end
you know
you